the gyro can experience a my uh my
brother and sister lived down there and
my brother got a gun pulled on him
whoa yeah but like a delivery driver
well so there so my brother yeah little
baby my little niece and there with her
is my brother in her in the back and
then uh he's driving us in the
neighborhood he's going the speed limit
right like maybe like five to ten miles
an hour I'm a little slower and there's
a delivery driver behind him delivery
driver gets mad starts honking Adam is
behind him right
my brother-in-law pulls into their
driveway delivery driver pulls in behind
him and is like what do you want to do
man and she flashes a gun on them and my
brother who's like he's as big as you
he's like a bodybuilder and he's uh he
was like I don't do anything man he's
like I don't know why you're honking I
mean I got my daughter in the back you
know she's like less than a year old and
the guy is just like I'm not making this
a race thing he's like I'm not saying
this is a race thing
and the kid yeah so he's just like well
and in my team I my brother was in the
military they could come calling the
guys sir and the guys like you called me
sir you in the military and he's just
like I am sorry I'm in the military he's
just like your disgrace to the military
and he's just like I just went slow
enough because my daughter's in the back
and you're behind me so he's like I
don't understand what the deal is here
and the guys just kept just trying to
egg him on to try to like provoke a
fight because of standing your ground oh
yeah I mean it was what I heard about I
was terrified my sister was shook she
had come home from work because it's
like you know the baby's in the back and
this guy's just like pulled up into your
driveway and he's just like if Quincy
would have made him move and that guy
shot him that God had been in the right
how much of that's going on it's
probably happening all the time look we
have in a Trayvon that's a uniquely
incompetent secure are two though I mean
he was getting smashed he's getting his
head bounced off my 15 year old right
now a kid was [ __ ] him up yeah hold
that gun out I mean they haven't
afforded to it wasn't a parking lot
right we're a guy like thought he was
being threatened by a dude with his kids
in the car and then he shot the guy
there's a parking lot in uh in Florida I
don't know that one oh that's for that
that's think I have the last year or
something but that's definitely a recent
look people just having guns all the
time seems like a great idea but the
people like that having guns yeah
because when it becomes a problem
somebody somebody knows that you don't
have a gun and they're trying to goad
you into something so that
you look yeah outlaw Josie Wales movie
like that's not someone defending
themselves so that's the weapon that's
that's why guns are creepy it's not
creepy because a guy like you has a gun
you're a great guy you're not gonna Rob
anybody no I don't need a gun you
wouldn't have a gun Yeah right but if
you did have a gun I wouldn't be nervous
I feel like well Moses has a gun he can
handle it yeah I'm not looking at yeah
most people that aren't good guys right
if those not good guys get a gun this
was the one he's talking about where the
guy was that's a big standard yeah he
was like on the ground with his hands up
and he got shot still really the guy
said he was felt threatened or something
I believe that's all they need is a
reason to mama that's all they need is a
reason to Florida
he's on the ground on his knees and the
guy shot him yeah oh my god yeah Jesus
Christ I mean when do you not shoot
someone if there are if if you you will
know you wouldn't shoot him Eve they
flattened out I mean I thought it was
always like if somebody's attacking you
I thought I mean that's your that's your
on the ax to flatten out yeah well I
know you to offer the money here yeah
here's I'm I think my life would you
accuse him I mean if he shot the guy was
the guy was flattened out what about
then do you think the same about being
me no I'm saying like yeah do you think
like they'd have the same reaction
cuz the reaction they had when they saw
him with his hands up honestly man yeah
yeah I don't know how mad you yeah I
don't how mad you are with the gun in
your head with a weapon in your hand to
be like I can I'm playing God run out of
this guy I can kill this man right now
this person right here right so yeah it
wouldn't matter would they accuse him
what I'm saying is would they accuse him
because they didn't he got away foot he
got away with it right he was accused
though right it wasn't charged for this
they didn't charge him that's what I'm
that's what I'm saying what that's what
I'm saying he wasn't arrested yes he's
deciding to stand your ground law I'm
reading right here from the AP sheriff
won't arrest parking lot shooter that's
also they can't even charge him no
that's what I'm saying that's that's
like that's like you can't challenge
that rule like in football you can't
that's not a he a wrestler he said he
felt threatened and the black guy was
just like dude I was on the ground
there's there's there's closed-circuit
footage of it you know but my question
was what if he had lied down lie down
flat on the ground with
and he be who I mean when would they
what at what would the line be that's
where they decide to charge him you know
saying right okay will you charge me is
lying down if the guys lied down just
execute them right is that still stand
your ground there there is a
manslaughter trial apparently now
updated as I've stated a teen
manslaughter oh we killed that guy hey
look call the sheriff as a defense
witness
that's insane insane there's certain
people that should have a gun right now
there's certain people a lot of you know
seasoned law enforcement people and
people with good dispositions that would
never in their [ __ ] wildest dreams
shoot someone who's on their knees would
never threaten anybody with a gun and
they have a gun purely for senseless for
self-defense that's a different thing
you know but there's when you have
everybody can have a gun that's you're
gonna get a certain number of those
[ __ ] guys yeah and they think wait a
minute they think they're in the right
yeah I think we all gotta get guns I
mean like is that nothing is not that
the move do we now get guns this is
America we can be racist and have guns
and be on drugs mmm well you have to be
on drugs now it's new right there's
gonna it's gonna come to a point I like
did you imagine how scared of you of
your kids to go to school though scary
right scare when you have children
you're very vulnerable you know you you
feel you feel more filled with love than
ever before but you also feel more
filled with fear because you're you're
worried
[Applause]